Cesar asks one camera crew to remain
inside and the other to stay behind the
fence until he can better assess the
nature of buddy's aggression
huh
oh look this is more territorial
aggression Davila standards Brown no no
no
none none none none
I'm gonna bring the camera guy
they ready to come in now we're gonna
you gotta follow me we got we gonna
leave it out he's now he's a little
nervous about it
you follow me we gonna we gonna make him
surrender the whole point see now he's
giving us his territory he's walking
away we're not gonna take a risk we're
not gonna take the muscle off we first
have to make sure we claim the territory
ears back head low that's good
the growling he's unsure his ears back
watch how you move there you go cuz
don't but the good thing is he's not the
aggressive type of pit bull he can be
bad if you moved the wrong way that's
right back there you go see it that's
pretty cool
so you can protest as much as you want
yeah yeah all right just me going into
this position give some axes so I'm not
overpowering too much you know too
strong I'm taking over I'm I'm becoming
his protector I want him to trust I'm
the guy who can actually save your life
buddy there we go